هنا تدخلت النقطتين الاستاذ رجاء عليهم
وهي ال ال ال ال البعد السياسي وده مش
ضغوط سياسيه ده عقليا جمعيه عقل جماعي
بيفكر ميسره المحايمن عليه الفكر اليساري
اللي هو حتى بيلغي اي حد حاجه مخالفه له
والعمل التجاري بمعنى ان الهجوم اللي شانه
وصحفيين ومؤرخين معاصرين كانوا شهود على
العصر لا ده ما حصلش دي اثاره زوبعه وفضول
عن الناس اصلا بنتفرجوا بقى على مسلسل
جانب التجاري منها لكن الفكر الجماعي عند
القائمين على الاعمال الفنيه والمسيطرين
على الميديا والصحافه اللي بيسموها اعلام
وكل ده بيسيطر عليها الفكر الجمعي قال يا
شريف ده فكره جمهوري مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
معادي للعولمه معادله الملكيه بالمناسبه
للعرب مع الكشف ههه التعاون المتشدد وما
الى ذلك فهو ايضا العاملين تدخلوا مع بعض
هنا في هذا العام لان حتى لا الشعوريه
الياشارين الليبراليين اللي هم بيخلقوا
هذه الاعمال الدراميه والفنيه عندهم ده
فالحين ان مصر الافلام الحرب العالميه
الثانيه الموجهه ما كانتش تاريخيه هي كانت
البطوله والتضحيات في
الطيران البريطاني همم لما كان مثلا
بريطانيا واقفه لوحدها عن الغواصات عن
السلاح البحري مثلا الحاجات اللي انا
فوجئت بها انا بتكلم مع واحده من البي بي
سي مصريه هي مقتنعه تماما ان مصر انتصرت
في حرب 56 في حين النص الاسطول المصري غدا
كان هي مقتنعه ان في قطعه بحريه بريطانيه
اغرقت وهذا غير صحيح لكن الافلام المصريه
صورتها
دي كانت طبعا مقبوله سياسيه كسيا موجهه
لكن احنا بنتكلم هنا عن تاريخ
وانت زي ما قلت استاذ مشاري ان هو فعلا
الفكر الجمعي
للعقل الخلاق في الدراما والاعلام
البريطاني
ارسال الهواء معادل الملكيه ويريد ان يعيد
كتاب التاريخ بان العصر الامبراطوري
البريطاني كان كله عصر سيء ويجب التخلص
منه